[MUSIC PLAYING]
- So we're going to
move a little farther.
We're going to go from
Earth to space now.
And so our next panel
is going to come up
here, join me on the stage.
And while they're
coming, I'm just
going to take my
prerogative, because I'm
going to let Dave
Charbonneau, who's
my colleague from the
astronomy department-- he's
a professor in the astronomy
department and also a Harvard
College professor here at
Harvard University, which
means he's an exceptional
teacher, which you're
going to see how great he
is in just a few minutes.
But I'm going to
take my prerogative
to ask him a question
before he actually starts.
And it's about clarifying
what we mean today
by the undiscovered.
And so I'm just a tiny
bit older than Dave
so that when he was a graduate
student here at Harvard,
I was actually on the committee
that decides whether or not
students can do particular
projects for their PhD thesis.
And some of you
may know that Dave
is extremely famous
for having discovered
the first so-called
transiting exoplanet, which
means a planet that passes
between us and its host star
and makes the star go a little
tiny bit dimmer by like one
millionth of its light.
And the technique that
he used to do that
was something that
should absolutely work.
But nobody had
ever made it work.
But everybody knew that it
would work, maybe, someday.
In other words, it
was not undiscovered,
it was undiscovered.
So in other words,
it was sitting
there waiting to be discovered.
But it wasn't a technique
that you wouldn't
think would ever, ever work.
It just hadn't worked yet.
But then the planets that
were found around other stars
are every variety
of bizarre, which
is what you're about to
hear about in this session.
And so for you, Dave, I want
to know whether you consider--
you don't have to
answer now, later--
but your original discovery
as undiscovered discovery
or just plain
discovery by the almost
traditional scientific method.
So I'll just leave it there
and turn it over to Dave
to introduce everyone
else in the session.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
- All right, so if you
look at the written
record of human thought,
it's pretty clear
that for at least 500 years
and arguably for 2,500 years,
humans have wondered whether
there were other worlds that
were inhabited and whether
or not we could somehow
come into contact with those
worlds and explore them.
And what I want
to begin by saying
is that this is a very special
moment in human history
where we're going to do
something very special, which
is that we have
for the first time
the technological ability
to actually go and answer
that question.
And so there's a great
deal of excitement
worldwide amongst astronomers
and astrobiologists
that really within
the next 10 years
we might detect the
presence of life
on planets orbiting other stars.
And so we're going to talk about
these exoplanets here today.
We have two of the
world's experts
and leading thinkers on
this really great question.
Our second speaker is going to
be Professor Lisa Kaltenegger,
who is the director of the
Carl Sagan Institute at Cornell
where she is also
professor of astronomy.
And there are few souls,
on this planet at least,
who have thought more
deeply and for longer
than what it would really take
to infer the presence of life
through telescopic observations.
So among many of the
exciting questions
that Lisa has investigated
are what would the earth look
like to an alien astronomer?
And how did the
Earth's appearance
change to that alien astronomer
as a function of time?
The Earth has not always
appeared as it now does.
Could we detect the presence
of geological activity
like volcanoes if you were
a remote astronomer gazing
across the vastness of space?
And which stars we
should begin by looking
at as we go and do
this exploration
with our telescopes.
Our first speaker, though,
will be Laura Kreidberg.
And Dr. Kreidberg is a junior
fellow in the Harvard Society
of Fellows.
And maybe to set up a
bit of a juxtaposition
for the purpose of this talk,
whereas Lisa is the theorist,
Laura is the observer.
And Dr. Kreidberg is
really a world leader
in using novel techniques
and pushing observatories
to achieve unprecedented
levels of precision
to go out and actually figure
out what these planets are made
of and what are the properties
of their atmospheres
and whether or not
they are anything
at all like that of the Earth.
And so I'm very excited
about this discussion.
And I'm going to call on Dr.
Kreidberg to lead us off.
[APPLAUSE]
- All right, thank
you, everybody.
It's my pleasure to be here.
And I have the honor of speaking
about a topic that really ties
together all of the themes
of today, which are life,
the earth, and space, which
is the question of is there
life elsewhere?
And as Dave said, humans
have been thinking
about this for a long time.
I would guess before
recorded history,
humans have been
thinking about this.
But the place I'd
like to start is
in the early 1960s when
an astronomer named
Frank Drake developed the
first scientific framework
for talking about the
possibility of detecting
inhabited planets in the galaxy.
And so he wrote down
this famous equation.
It looks like it's not there.
Well, I'm not allowed to have
equations in talks anyway,
so that's fine.
So the way Frank Drake
thought about this
was he started by
saying, OK, well,
how many stars
are in the galaxy?
Presumably you need
the star as a source
of energy for your life.
And then he said,
how many of those
stars host planets, in
particular planets that
are likely to be habitable?
We'll come back to that later.
And finally, how often
does life actually
arise on those potentially
habitable planets?
And if it does arise,
can we detect it?
And so the goal was
to get a number--
number of potentially
detectable inhabited planets
in the galaxy.
And this all sounds fine.
It's a very organized
way of thinking about it.
The problem was that
in 1961, nobody knew
what any of these terms were.
And the way it was
approached was the way
we were all taught as
young scientists, which
is to develop a
hypothesis and then try
to figure out an
experiment you could
use to test that hypothesis.
And so if your
hypothesis is that there
are other stars in the
galaxy that host planets like
the earth, then your
experiment is can you detect
these Earth-like planets?
And so folks went
through this exercise
of trying to figure out how
we would go about doing that.
And so the most natural
first question is to say,
can we just take a
picture of the planet,
maybe block out the
light from the star?
And it turns out that
this is very, very hard,
that the earth is 10 billion
times fainter than the sun.
And not only is it
much, much fainter,
it's also very close to it.
And so the analogy
is that this is
very similar to trying to detect
a firefly next to a lighthouse
at a distance of a
couple of hundred miles.
And so this was ruled
out as impossible.
OK, good.
So another idea was
to try to search
for a transit of the planet.
This is when you get
lucky with your geometry
and the planet goes directly
in front of its parent star.
And when it does
that, it blocks,
as Alyssa said, a tiny
fraction of the stellar light.
The challenge is that
for an earth-sized planet
around a sun-like star,
it's only one part in 10,000
of the stellar brightness
that gets blocked.
And that was considered also
too difficult to detect.
Not only is it difficult to
detect, it's fairly improbable.
Only half a percent
of the time would
you expect this chance alignment
to work out in your favor.
And it only happens once a year.
And so even if you
did somehow build
a detector that could see it,
suppose next year you went back
to try to detect
it again and you're
observing from the
ground, could be cloudy.
It could be daytime.
You might not be able
to see it at all.
Folks also thought about
trying to detect the influence
of the planet on the stars.
So planets have some mass.
And we normally think of
the star as fixed in space,
but the planet is
orbiting around.
But really the planet's gravity
tugs on the star a little bit,
and it makes it wobble.
And so you could
imagine that maybe you
could detect that wobble
by observing the spectrum
of the star, the color.
And when the star is
moving towards you,
its light is a little
bit blueshifted just
by the Doppler effect,
the same thing that
makes a siren sound
higher pitched
as it's coming towards you and
lower pitched as it moves away.
And then as the
planet moves away--
as the star moves away
from you, its light
would be then redshifted.
The problem here
is that the size
of the signal, the
amount of motion induced
by the earth on the sun
is only 10 centimeters
a second, which was far too
difficult for any detector
at the time to ever see.
And so even though this is
such an exciting question,
everyone was saying, oh, there's
no way, this is too hard,
except for a handful of very
persistent, very stubborn
people.
One of these was Paul Butler.
And he described what it
was like to try to search
for extrasolar planets in 1986.
And what he said
was, "When asked
by other astronomers,
what are you working on,
one could not
respond, I'm searching
for extrasolar planets.
Depending on the person,
they might laugh in your face
or slowly move away from
you like you were pitching
an alien conspiracy theory."
But nevertheless, they tried.
They kept going.
And this is an amazing,
amazing figure.
This is the discovery data
for an extrasolar planet
that was completely unlike
anything that was ever
seen in the solar system.
So this was from a team of
astronomers who were using
the Doppler wobble technique.
And they measured the velocity
of a star called 51 Pegasi.
And this is what they saw.
They saw these
characteristic wiggles
that are exactly
what you would expect
if you have a planet tugging
your star back and forth.
The crazy thing about
this is that the amplitude
of that signal was 100
meters per second compared
to 10 centimeters a second
for what you would expect
for an earth-like planet.
And so I love this quote
from a colleague of mine,
Emily Levesque, where she
said, "The real exciting sound
in science is not Eureka,
it's huh, that's weird."
And that is exactly
what we're seeing here.
So the inference
here is that in order
to have a signal
that large, you have
to have a planet comparable
in size to Jupiter
orbiting its parent star
in about three days.
And this was considered
absolutely crazy.
There's no way a planet
could form there.
We think that the
material that goes
into forming
Jupiter-like planets
would all be vaporized at
temperatures as high as you
would get so close to the star.
And yet here it was.
And even still, there
were detractors.
People thought this was
so nuts that maybe it
was something on the star,
maybe it was star spots,
maybe it was just something else
until about five years later
when Dave, who we're
fortunate to have here today,
decided nah, we have to prove
this for real, and went out
and searched for
transits of the planets.
And so I'm glad that Alyssa
was amenable to letting him go
do this as a graduate student.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
So this was viewed
with some skepticism.
Is that right, Dave?
- There's a whole back story.
[LAUGHTER]
But I do like that plot.
- And so this was the
absolute unmistakable proof
that these signals have
to be caused by a planet.
So this was a star that had a
detected radio velocity signal.
The star was wobbling.
And then Dave went out
and looked exactly when
he expected the planet to
transit in front of its host
star and saw this characteristic
dimming of about a percent.
And so this was the
push that everybody
needed to say, oh,
maybe there actually
are planets around other stars.
And they might not have
to be like the planets
in this solar system.
And so the floodgates opened.
And there are now
over a dozen searches
using both the transit
technique and the stellar wobble
technique that have been going
on for over two decades now.
And so I'll fast forward to what
our picture of exoplanets looks
like today.
And this is what we found.
This is the plot showing
the pace of discovery.
This is the number
of known planets,
number of discovered
planets detected every year
between 1995 and today.
There are almost 4,000 of them.
We know now that the average
star hosts at least one planet
typically.
Some have many more.
And the diversity of
planets is much greater
than we ever could have
imagined from the solar system.
So not only did we see these
hot Jupiter-like planets,
the very first ones
that were discovered,
we also see many planets
that are intermediate in size
between the Earth and Neptune.
We have no solar system
analog for those planets.
We see many, many, many
planets on orbits interior
to that of Mercury, which is
the closest planet to the sun.
We see planets
orbiting stars that
are very different from the
sun, stars that are larger,
stars that are
smaller and cooler.
And as the excitement
about this grew,
so did our technological
capabilities.
And so that original
question of are there other
Earth-like planets
suddenly became something
that was within our reach.
And what we now know is that
roughly 10% to 20% of stars
host an Earth-size
planet with temperatures
appropriate for liquid
water on the surface, which
is the canonical
definition for the places
we're most excited
to try to find life.
And so here we are.
We're at this sort
of crossroads.
Going back to the
Drake equation,
we now know what a
bunch of the terms are.
We know that there's about 300
billion stars in the galaxy,
that almost all of those stars
host at least one planet,
and that very,
very many of those
planets are
potentially habitable.
And so the question
for me is what do we
do about these last two pieces?
How often does life develop?
How can we go about
detecting that life?
And there are a couple
of ways to go about this.
We're going to hear later
in the afternoon from Jill
about technosignatures.
I'm going to talk
about something
a little bit different, which
is searching for biosignatures
in the atmospheres
of these planets.
And this is a little
bit of a gamble.
So I really liked what Stuart
talked about this morning
about searching for a
black cat in a dark room.
That definitely feels like what
I do in my day-to-day work.
But it's not exactly--
it's not a bumbling search.
We make these guesses
to say, oh you know,
maybe the cat is sitting
on top of the dryer
because it's warm up there.
That's where we would
expect a cat to normally be.
And so when I think about that
undiscovered in science, to me
it feels a lot like a
sort of calculated gamble.
I grew up in Nevada.
I know about gambling.
And so the gamble
that I'm taking
is to study some earth-sized
planets in the habitable zones
of their host stars.
But these planets are very,
very different from the sun.
And that's because they're
orbiting much smaller stars
that are a lot cooler.
And there's a lot of
advantages to doing this.
We know that small
stars are actually
much more common than
sun-like stars in the galaxy.
So this figure shows
the sun would be one
of these bright yellow circles.
These are all of the stars
within about 10 parsecs,
so very nearby to the sun.
And you can see that most of
them are quite a bit smaller.
Not only are small
stars more common,
the habitable zone
is also closer in.
So if you're searching
for transiting planets,
the transits are more frequent,
the transit probability
is higher, and most importantly
the planet is much larger
relative to the star.
And so they're easier
to characterize.
And excitingly, we've started to
detect a lot of these planets.
It's so exciting that it
made the Google Doodle, which
I think is a sign
that you've made it
as a scientist when your results
end up on the Google homepage.
So I really identify with
the moon in this animation.
So yeah, we now know
of about a dozen
nearby terrestrial planets
orbiting these very small stars
where we have some hope of
studying their atmospheres
and searching for signs of life.
However, there are some
caveats that I should mention.
And this is why
this is risky, which
is that small stars are very,
very different from the sun.
They are bright in
the ultraviolet,
so they emit a lot of
high-energy radiation
in their young lifetimes that
can be very dangerous to life
trying to develop on the surface
of the planets orbiting them.
It could also evaporate the
atmosphere of the planet.
So we're not sure whether
planets around these stars
can even hold on to
atmospheres at all.
They have powerful flares
that could also disrupt
the development of life.
And finally, the planets are
expected to be tidally locked
to the stars.
That is to say they have a hot
day side and a cold night side,
just like the moon is tidally
locked by the Earth's gravity.
And in this situation,
you can imagine
that you're not going to
have a smooth temperature all
the way around the
surface of your planet.
You'll have a really hot part.
You'll have a cold part.
You might worry about
your atmosphere freezing
out on the cold side, so you
get a snow cone situation
where there's ice on one side
and rock on the other side.
And so there are a
lot of detractors
who argue against
searching for atmospheres,
searching for signs of
life on planets like this.
But I think that's silly.
And so this is what I do.
I'm interested in trying
to measure the compositions
of the atmospheres.
This is a little
animation showing how
we would go about doing this.
And the idea is that when the
planet is in front of the star,
a tiny fraction of
the starlight will
filter through the
planet's atmosphere.
And it can get
absorbed by molecules
that are present there.
And depending on what
the molecules are,
they have different
opacities, different levels
of transparency at
different wavelengths.
And so if we measure the size of
the planet in different colors,
we can work backwards
and figure out what
the atmosphere is made out of.
And just to illustrate with
a more close-to-home example,
this is what the Earth
looks like in the infrared.
That's the moon
in the background.
And if I move to a
different wavelength
where ozone is very
opaque, it looks like this.
You can see these
small differences.
And so that's what we're
looking for in the atmospheres
of these other planets.
This actually works.
This is my one science
result that I'll show you.
We don't have yet
the sensitivity
to look at planets
that are this small.
But this is a planet
similar to Neptune.
And we detected water
in its atmosphere.
So those two big bumps are where
the planet radius is larger
because water vapor is absorbing
and blocking the stellar light.
And so what we
expect is very soon,
not with telescopes that
we have available yet,
but in the near future
with James Webb, which
is the successor to the
Hubble Space Telescope,
that we're going to
start to be able to make
these measurements for
Earth-sized planets
around the smallest stars.
And so this is a
result from a paper
I wrote with my office
mate, Caroline Morley.
And we were sitting
around, and we were saying,
OK, we have no idea what the
atmospheres of these planets
are going to be like.
And so to deal with
that uncertainty,
we said, well, we could use the
solar system as inspiration.
We have different
kinds of atmospheres
for the solar system planets.
And so here we were
like, well, maybe it
has an atmosphere
like the earth that
has a lot of water
vapor in it or maybe it
has an atmosphere
more like Venus
that is dominated by
CO2, carbon dioxide,
or instead it
could have methane,
which is a situation we see on
Titan, one of Saturn's moons.
And so we made a
prediction for what
the signal should look like for
these different atmospheres.
And we found that
this is something
we will be able to detect
using the James Webb Space
Telescope with a fairly
reasonable amount of observing
time.
And so this is something
we can look forward to
within the next
five years or so.
And normally when
I talk about this,
I feel like I have to--
like I'm on the job market
and I have to have some sort
of punch line where I say,
oh yes, and this will tell us
that the planet is inhabited
or not.
And for the purposes
of this talk,
I'll be honest and
say we have no idea.
We have absolutely no
idea what we will find.
But we're trying to design
an experiment in a smart way
where we can learn at least
the very beginning of what
kind of chemical inventory
these planets might
have so we can start assessing
whether they host life or not.
And so to end, I'll leave you
with a quote from Frank Drake.
I had the honor of meeting
him a couple of years ago.
And the question I had for him
was knowing what we know now,
what do you think the chances
are of discovering life
elsewhere?
And he said, "100%."
But I'll add the caveat
to that, that in order
to find that life, we have to
keep an open mind about how
and where we search.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- So thank you to Laura
for this great introduction
to what we're trying to do,
what we're trying to achieve.
And Dave already mentioned this.
If you just take a
second to think that we
are the generation that might.
We have the technological
possibility,
but we don't know
how hard it is going
to be to actually spot life,
if they're unique signatures.
That's what we're
going to talk about.
But we are the first generation
in all of human history
that has the chance to
figure out if we are alone
in the universe.
It's us.
I think that is one of the
most amazing times ever.
And sometimes people pick when
they would like to be born.
And I would pick
now all the time,
because living in
the time where are
we going to get this connection
to the cosmos, where we're
going to look up at the stars
and not just statistically
right now say 1,
2, 3, 4, 5, right?
One out of five
stars has a planet
small enough and at the right
distance-- not too hot or too
cold.
So maybe, just maybe, that
could be also inhabited there.
It's potentially habitable.
Whether there's life is
another complete question.
But we have the
technological means
to actually figure this out.
And whatever else
you might think
is going wrong in our life,
this is not one of these things.
We are the explorers of
our centuries, I would say.
And I'm sure it was
great for Columbus
to actually find the New World.
But we have an S on him.
We have new worlds,
thousands of new worlds
that we are discovering.
And so in the context
of this meeting,
I wanted to add
another aspect to this.
So [INAUDIBLE] science
with new techniques,
and Laura was saying
that with new telescopes,
we could [? get ?] more detail
and more detailed information.
But I like this Schoppenhauer
quote where he actually says,
"The task is not so much to
see what no one yet has seen,
but to think what
nobody yet has thought
about that that everyone sees."
So what I want to
do and what I'm
going to try to do right now--
so first I'm going to show you
a couple of amazing artists'
impression to
visualize our data.
This is one of them.
So what you actually have here--
hopefully this will run, yes--
is just a representation
of how diverse
these other solar systems are.
So what you see here
is actually-- oops,
this did not work.
Each of the circles
represents one
of the hundreds of planetary
systems that we have detected.
And yes, grant you,
the planets are not
that big compared to the star.
But the planet
compared to each other
are these big dots
that go around.
And you see some just
need a couple of days
to go around their star.
So if you ever
wanted to be older,
celebrate a birthday
on 51 [INAUDIBLE]
B. It only has a year
from Monday morning
to Friday afternoon.
Incredibly hot.
That Jupiter is evaporating
right now because it's
so close to its sun.
So if you look at it
in a billion years,
it will look different
because it will have
lost part of its atmosphere.
But with more and
more observation time,
we are finding planets
that are more and more
in a temperate zone and
especially, as Laura
was saying, around
these cool stars,
because of course
stars [? work with ?]
nuclear fusion in the core.
But you can think
about it as a bonfire.
If you have a big bonfire,
a big star like our own sun,
you have to be a certain
distance away to be warm--
too close, you're too hot.
But if the star is
smaller, you need
to be closer in for the
same amount of warmth
to get to you,
radiation to get to you.
And so we looked.
That's what you should
always do in science.
And we were looking
for patterns.
And it turns out that these
small stars are the most
abundant in the universe.
About 75% of all stars are
these small, red stars.
And they tend or they make rocky
planets incredibly efficiently.
So mother nature in a
way did us a great favor,
for us astronomers and
for a search for life
in the universe, that
where we can actually
find planets that could
potentially be like the earth,
she made more of them.
And so we were off
to a very good start,
because it could have gone
completely the other way.
And so what I want to
talk to you about today is
that with all of this,
with thousands of planets
that we've already discovered
around other stars' alien suns,
now what are we looking for?
And Laura gave you this
beautiful introduction to,
well, let's say the whole
atmosphere's CO2, right?
Then if I look at
it, part of the light
will be blocked out because
it will hit CO2 molecules.
And a certain energy
will make a certain atom
or certain molecules
swing and rotate.
It has to have a certain
energy that's a certain color.
So think about it this way.
The light from the star
hits the planets air,
gets filtered through it, and
then comes to my telescope.
So if there are
molecules and atoms
in this air that the light
can hit, that it can strike,
less of the light comes
out on the other side.
So I'm on my telescope looking
at this, and I'm a theorist,
but as soon as we find these
exciting planets where there
are biosignatures,
I will also use
the data, as Laura has amazing
done already and David.
But what I'm saying
is that by what's
missing in the light getting
to my telescope, that's
what tells me what the
chemical composition
of these other worlds are like.
And with the next telescopes
that we're building,
we actually can start to
figure out whether or not
these small, rocky walls
could be anything like ours,
but of course not
just ours right now,
because the earth has
changed through time.
And when I teach this
in Astronomy 101,
I have a big intro class
that I love to teach.
And I say, what is one thing if
anybody ever came with a time
machine and said, you
can go back to the past
or up to the future, what's the
one thing you need to bring?
And it's usually a camera.
I'm like congratulations,
you're opening
the door of the time machine.
And you did, because the gas
or the atmospheric composition
of our planet was
completely different when
it was young than it is now.
We had no oxygen
initially, for example.
What was going on
while the dinosaur
roams is different than
what's going on right now.
And probably in the future
things will be different, too.
So I tell them to take a
gas mask or their own oxygen
plus a camera, because yes,
I would like a picture.
And no, you cannot
make a time machine.
[INAUDIBLE] that.
That's just my
theoretical question.
But let me bring you back
in time a little bit.
41 years ago, we've
actually sent out
our first message in a bottle,
human kind's message to space.
That was Voyager 1
with the golden record.
And Carl Sagan at
Cornell led the team
that put together a
representative idea of what
the music and the
art of humankind
would be in this
message in a bottle.
And so we sent this mission out.
It had a scientific
mission, Voyager 1 in 1977.
It went to the outer planets.
It told us a lot of
exciting science.
And then it took a last swing
by and basically made its way
towards the next star
with our message on it
and a very cute
quote to music lovers
everywhere on it
and a description
of how to build a record
player in case some aliens came
across it.
And I won't say much
more, because Jill
is going to talk more
about technology signatures
and intelligent life.
But to say before
Voyager did that, left
Earth's solar
system, it basically
looked back one last time to
look at our own world, our home
world.
That's what Carl Sagan
named the pale blue dot.
And he wrote a beautiful
piece about it.
But if you look up here on
the right, the small dots,
that is us.
And he said, everybody
who's ever loved,
everybody who's ever lived.
And he goes in big
detail on about this love
for this one world, the one
world we know can sustain life.
And I will go with
the session before us.
Please let it sustain life
for much longer, because we
have found other worlds.
But we can't tell you if any of
them is a good vacation place.
And we have no way to get there.
So on the flip side,
you really don't
have to worry about
anybody coming here either,
because these things
are light years away.
And so if you take
our whole solar system
and it's the size of about a
cookie, then the next star,
this next alien sun--
and the amazing thing
is even that one
has a planet that could
potentially be like ours--
is two football fields away.
So travel is not
a possibility yet.
However, these worlds teach us.
They can teach us also
about how worlds evolve
in the first place
and when we can
start to analyze the small
ones, how worlds like our Earth
can actually evolve
in the future,
give us an insight
into a long-term future
of habitable worlds like ours.
So even if you don't care if
there's life anywhere else,
you kind of should care in
the long run what happens
to our own planet hopefully.
And that is one of
the other answers
that we can actually
help with, because we
have more examples,
thousands of other worlds
where we can start to
understand the atmosphere
and the dynamics.
So if you have this tiny
dot, what you'd like to have,
of course, is a
picture like this--
oceans, continents, clouds.
But it's too far away.
So what you can do is you
can look at the light.
Instead of actually
splitting out into sectors--
this is where there's a coast.
This is [INAUDIBLE] oceans.
You can split it
up into its light,
so from red to blue for example.
And just have a look, it's
a spectrum like a rainbow.
So basically when
there's a raindrop,
it splits the white light
from the sun in its colors.
And then as I said
before, you look and see
which colors are missing.
And so this should be a smooth
curve, but it's really not.
And so where there's
something missing,
it's not smooth, like
a bite out of an apple.
That tells you where
the energy of the light
was just right to make the
molecules swing and rotate.
We're looking in the
infrared right now.
And that's unique, because
of course an oxygen, O2,
looks different
than, for example,
an ozone molecule, three Os.
So a different kind of
energy is needed for it
to start to swing and rotate.
So by figuring out
what's missing,
you can see here the makeup
of the air in our own planet.
So you see ozone.
You see methane and
water and also CO2.
And the combination of ozone
and oxygen, either of the two,
with methane, a reducing gas,
is the telltale sign for life
as we know it, because we can't
produce it with biology alone.
Oxygen and methane will
react to water and CO2.
So if you still see oxygen
and methane in the air,
what that tells you is that
something is producing it
in huge amounts right now.
And for oxygen, we have
no other explanation
than that being life.
So that's our way to say
OK, if you look at the Earth
from far away, this is
how you could figure out
there's actually a
biota, life on it.
And this spectral fingerprint
or this light fingerprint
is unique for the planets
in our own solar system.
What you see here is
Venus, Earth, and Mars
and then down here two of
the other exciting places
in the solar system we're
interested in for life,
Titan on the left and
Europa in the middle here.
But how do you translate this?
Of course we can use
it as a template.
And that's what we
study and what we do.
But how do you
translate that further
to a planet that is
nothing like or that's
not a carbon copy of
planets in our solar system?
And this is where the theory
of understanding planets
and atmosphere, interiors of
planets, how they interact
with the air, how they
interact with the heat coming
from the star comes in
in our undiscovered--
in this idea of this
undiscovered box
of what could be out there and
what we should be looking for.
But as a first step, we can
just use our planet again
as a Rosetta stone, Earth.
We know that it
differs through time.
About 4.6 billion years
ago, it got formed.
And if you put this on a kind
of a 24-hour clock if you want,
about 3 AM is when life
started on the earth.
And about lunchtime
is when it started
to release oxygen in the air.
So before that, I don't
have a way to identify it.
Even so it was there, it
only made methane or CO2.
And that I can also
make geologically.
So it's not so much
that it's not there.
It's more that it doesn't
leave us with a unique sign.
So in this undiscovered
parameter space,
we not only have to find
worlds that could be like ours
or could host life like ours.
We also have to find worlds
that we can identify such life
uniquely, because we'll go
with Carl Sagan here again.
He said, "extraordinary
results better
have extraordinary
evidence behind them."
And so this is a view of
how our planet changed,
again an artist's
impression, of course.
But you see from
early on to now.
And that brought with it
a change in biota as well.
So intelligent life, I
took Einstein for that.
So we're going with we
have intelligent life here.
But I'm going to
wait for Jill's talk
and see whether or not she
agrees with that assessment.
But all this again translates
into this light fingerprint.
Our planet looked different
when it was young.
It looks different now.
And it will look
different in the future.
But it's something
that we can catch
with these advanced telescopes
that we're building.
And it won't be easy whatsoever.
And I would like to
tell you that it's
going to be easy to do
with this new 6.5 meter
telescope, the James
Webb Space Telescope.
So it's going to be
about four times my size
in space, what's great.
However, it's going
to be at the limit
of our technical
capabilities to find it.
And this is, of course, why
we need excellent observers
like Laura and Dave
to make this work
to let us find these features.
This is what one of the
telescopes looks like.
It's one of the extremely
large telescopes envisioned
to be in Chile.
It's a 40 meter
telescope on the ground
because you have to take out
the atmospheric disturbance
on the image you
collect from the ground,
so it needs to be bigger.
And this is the telescope,
the James Webb Space Telescope
we should be launching in 2021.
And while saying
that, we have just
launched this year an
amazing small telescope,
the test satellite
that is actually
not just giving us statistics,
because I said count to five,
one out of five stars has a
planet that could be like ours.
This test satellite that we
just launched in April this year
actually started taking
science data in July.
And it's telling you
which of these stars
actually does have the
planets that could potentially
be like ours.
And it's going to give us our
closest travel destination.
Even so, this is going
to be in the far future.
But in the last
couple of minutes,
what I wanted to show you
is now this is undiscovered.
And this is out-of-the-box
thinking that we need
to actually find life in
different environments.
We can use Earth
as a Rosetta stone.
But we basically
are not just going
to use life on earth like
plants and everything you see.
We use life in the deep oceans
or we use life like water bears
that basically survive
kind of everything.
They even took them to the
International Space Station,
put them out, no shelter.
Three days later, they put
them back in, put water on,
and it was like da, da, da,
da, da, I'm fine, right?
So life is incredibly
diverse and versatile even
on our own planet.
And in our search,
we need to put that
into our search strategy.
We cannot just look for a planet
that's exactly a copy of ours,
because even with billions
of planets in our own solar
system, the chances to find one
that's exactly like ours right
now is probably not as high
as you'd like it to be.
But if it's just a
little bit different,
we already know of life
that can survive there.
So if you, for example,
walk through Yellowstone,
all these beautiful
colors is actually
biota that lives in
different conditions.
And this is just a
really funny cartoon.
It's like, what do you
mean extreme, right?
Because what's extreme for
us, for other life [INAUDIBLE]
of the earth, for other
biota is perfectly fine.
It's where they strive.
So the analog for what
conditions allow for life
on the earth are much
bigger than what we usually
think about, because we don't
think about these extreme forms
of life.
And so one of my PhD students
put together a color catalogue
of life for going to many, many
different places on the earth,
taking this biota, and
then saying how would
it actually look like if you
saw a planet that was dominated,
let's say by an algae
bloom or by something else?
And it changes the
color and probably also
the atmospheric composition.
So this is, in a way, the
undiscovered and thinking
outside of your box or at
least find other people
who have different boxes and
put all of that information
together.
And of course, the star also
has a huge influence on it.
Whether or not that life
gets hit by red light
or by white light is a different
influence in its evolution.
And we don't know
much about this,
because we only have
our own Earth that
was hit by white light.
But these small stars,
as Laura was saying,
are also incredibly active.
So what would life have to
do to survive like huge UV
on the surface?
And Laura was talking
about life on the surface,
because of course
life can [? shelter ?]
on the water or can
[? shelter ?] on the ground.
And then it doesn't
matter how much
UV radiation hits the surface.
However, we were trying
again to think out
of the box in our research and
were saying, what does life do?
What are the different
strategies of life
if you hit it with a lot of UV?
And these are algae
that you see here
that when you hit it, actually
it starts to biofluoresce,
because it lives in
symbiosis with algae.
The corals start
to biofluoresce,
because they live in
symbiosis with algaes
that can survive UV radiation.
And so it's not to
say at all that that
would happen on another planet.
But it is a strategy
that life on a very high
irradiated environment could
take to actually mitigate
this harsh UV environment.
And actually biofluorescence
on the earth, we use it.
We don't use the corals,
because there's only
0.2% of all the surface of
the life of the earth that
has corals.
But this is how we actually
judge whether or not
plants are healthy.
We use fluorescence, because
plants also fluoresce.
Most of the things on the
earth actually fluoresce.
And if you go to
[INAUDIBLE] aquarium,
it's a little hard
to see, up here
you see this
biofluorescence corals.
So most of the aquarium,
if they have UV light,
these biofluorescent
corals are the ones
that if they were to make up
these other kind of worlds,
if that was an evolutionary
path that could work,
a really interesting
idea would be
you'd have this huge
flare on the star
and the planet next
to it would light up,
because it breaks down
the harsh UV radiation
and gives you additional
visible light.
So the way to think about
it, this undiscovered,
is also to think stretch
your imagination,
because we have this incredibly
diversity of worlds out there.
And using Earth
and all its facets,
not just anything we think about
every day, as a Rosetta stone,
is our one way to get at least
a little bit close to the answer
of how we could
find life out there.
And that's my last slide.
This is NASA's
artist travel poster
to a planet like TRAPPIST-1.
But I love the quote that an
author from San Francisco,
and he's contemporary, wrote
about our survey in the stars.
And he says, "One day, from
the shores of a new world,
we'll gaze at the sea
that took us there.
And the waves will be stars."
And that will be far,
far in the future.
However, what we
are doing right now,
these discoveries
we're making right now
is enabling humanity
or anybody who
comes after us to take
this next adventure.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
- OK, so we can kind of keep
this a little conversational.
And one thing in the theme--
there's so many great things
to talk about with exoplanets.
But really to get at the
theme of the undiscovered,
one thing that keeps me up
at night as an astronomer
is the role of our tools.
So we use telescopes.
That is our tool of choice.
And if I think about a
lot of the important steps
forward in exoplanets, we
talked all about atmospheres.
The first discovery
of an atmosphere
was made with the Hubble
Space Telescope, which
was conceived of and designed
and launched before we knew
of anything about exoplanets.
There was no concept that
people would ever use
the Hubble for that purpose.
Similarly, if you
think of the first time
we measured light from planets,
that was done with the Spitzer
Space Telescope.
Same story again.
So I just wanted to get
your thoughts on how--
the point is, should we design
our experiments to really
go and detect something very
specific or is there a danger
and should we build much
more general purpose
observatories, but by
nature they will not
be as penetrating on
a particular topic
and what the dangers are of
over-designing tools in a field
that is largely undiscovered?
- That's a great question.
I think that-- so someone
earlier brought up
the metaphor of searching
for your keys under the lamp
in the easiest place to look.
And I think there's something
to be said for that,
because there's--
and that was actually
presented as a negative.
But for us, the observing the
atmospheres of these planets
that are so small and so
far away is so technically
challenging that usually my
approach is to say, look,
I'll take whatever I can get.
Let's design something
that would give us
a reasonable chance of
learning about the atmosphere
of a planet like this and keep
an open mind about what exactly
the signal is that
we're trying to see.
So not-- so more
specifically, not just the I
want to detect oxygen on
an exact earth analog.
- Right.
But let me push on that a bit.
So Lisa, you showed all this
kind of great diversity of life
on the earth.
The truth is when we are
designing our experiments
to go and look for
life, we're really
looking for life that's
identical to that on the earth.
I mean, it's got to
be a rocky planet.
It's got to be the
same temperature.
It's got to have
oxygen and methane
and water in the atmosphere.
And is there a danger
to basically looking
for a mirror of ourselves?
And what would it take
to go and recognize
life that was fundamentally
different than life
on the earth?
Is that something that
we could aspire to do?
Are we basically shackled
in that, we could only
ever recognize life that's
so similar to the earth
that that's the only
thing we can look for?
- So I think there's two
parts of that answer.
And one part is that what
we learn from planets
is that they are very diverse.
So what you don't want to
do, what you definitely
don't want to do is
basically limit yourself to,
let's say, with this one,
I can find one molecule,
because I've now put all
my eggs in the basket
that oxygen is what
will define life,
because we'll figure out oxygen
you can make by splitting water
or by splitting CO2.
So giving you the
context is key.
And so if you can get as
much wavelength as you can,
that is your first information.
Split the light as far from one
side to the other as you can.
Get some information
on the temperature,
plus get a conformation
on the reflected light.
However, I think with this
big, multipurpose telescope
on one side, there is the
small explorer missions that
are key to our success,
because for example,
if I want to know how
much radiation really
hits my planet, I might not
need this huge, huge telescope,
but this small
dedicated telescope that
does this one just perfectly or
[INAUDIBLE] basically looking
all the closest nearby
stars to give me
the answer on which
of our closest stars
have potentially
habitable world.
I think the key
thing in science is
that we developing our tools.
And we'll always want to
have one big thing that
can do a lot, but we need
to keep it, I would say,
wavelengths [INAUDIBLE]
or energy wise as wide
as we can and then have these
complimentary small missions.
And the second point
that I haven't got to,
but very shortly.
If I know what to
look for, then I
can say this I can
only explain with life.
I can find other life.
We're looking for things
that look weird, right?
However, I won't be able
to tell you I know for sure
that this is life, because we
can't make life in the lab yet.
So what I mean is like
if silica-based life--
carbon has a lot of things
going for it, water too.
And we're looking
at this warm place
around the sun similar to what
the earth gets in energy, only
because the idea is that
if you have a huge ice
layer like for Europa, if
their gas is produced by life,
it gets trapped or it can get
trapped under the ice layer
and will never
make it to my air.
And the only thing I can assess
if I can't go there and drill
a hole in the ice is the air.
So I'm trying to make my
planets be where they're not
going to freeze over.
So I think there are
a couple of things
that go into this equation.
- OK.
So I think what we want to--
this is great.
I think what we want
to do is ask people
with questions to
come forward, to make
sure to use the microphones.
And we'll give you
a moment to step up.
- Hi, I'm Rachel
from [INAUDIBLE]..
So the stars that we're
looking at for having life,
they're light years away.
So technically we're
looking into the past.
So should we be
comparing our Earth
from the past and our atmosphere
as it was from the past
to those atmospheres,
because it has the potential
to change like we have changed
over the billions of years?
So yeah.
- Right.
And may I--
I can see a long
line of questions.
I see we have 10 minutes.
Can we do like two or
three sentence answers?
And that way we can really
kind of keep it going.
So--
- So the good
thing we have going
for us is the closest star,
the more light I get from it.
So I can only see things that
are only about 100 years away
that have planets around it.
But your question
is exactly right.
We see it like it
was four years ago
is the closest star, six
years, 10 years, 50 years ago.
And it could have
changed meanwhile.
But, fingers crossed,
they figured out
how to do climate
change and we're not
going to be too late when
we find signs of life.
- Thank you.
- OK, thank you.
Next.
- All right, hi.
I'm [INAUDIBLE].
And I'm also from
[INAUDIBLE] High School.
So in sci-fi movies
that you see today,
you usually see that the
aliens are more technically
inclined more than we are.
So what's to say that we're
not the ones that have the best
technology and not them?
- I think that's--
yeah, I think that's
a great point.
In my mind, there's
no clear indication
that intelligence is
actually evolutionarily
favorable at all.
- Oh, I think I would go--
- That's absolutely true.
- I think I would go for
the other way, sorry.
Just a quick question.
If there really life
everywhere could be,
then we're talking
about one in five stars.
We're talking about 40
billion planets out there.
And I have high hopes with
stars being older and younger
that some of them are
going to be further along
and some are going
to be less along.
The question is how
long they survived.
But I'm an optimist.
I think we're going to make it.
- I'm Tatiana, also
from [INAUDIBLE]..
And I've seen things on YouTube
talking about this Great
Barrier and if us
as humans, if we've
crossed that Great
Barrier and we've been
able to overcome that and that's
why we've been able to evolve.
What's your opinion on that?
Do you think we've actually
crossed that barrier?
- I think there's a very
fun sci-fi novel there.
There's actually
a really good one
where Reynolds is talking about
this, where he says, well,
you don't live long enough.
So once you're at
this threshold,
then some alien will
come and bring you there
so everybody can meet.
But I said I'm an
optimist by training.
I think life-- the problem
is we sometimes think of us.
Whether we're going
to make it, finding
another alien civilization
and communication with that,
I'm not sure.
However, that life
is still going
to be around when somebody
else comes looking for us,
I'm pretty sure.
It takes a lot to kill life
on the planet, fortunately.
It doesn't take that
much to kill us.
So we better be a bit careful.
- Hi.
I'm Colleen Ellis.
And you'll never
guess where I'm from.
So in our astronomy class, we
learn about really, really big
numbers.
And it's a lot of
17-year-olds disassociating
and having existential crises
at 8:00 in the morning.
How do you as professionals
deal with such large numbers
day in and day out?
- So I teach a class of
250 undergrad students.
They're just coming into
Cornell and love my class.
And so sometimes they also--
so the existential
crisis will stay.
It's just going to
become different.
This connection
[? is to the ?] stars.
Everyone can always look up
and you'll see those stars.
They're always going
to be with you.
Nobody can take those away.
In the Sahara Desert
when you have nothing
or when people have nothing
else, no TV, no technology
or something, they
still have the stars.
And so to me, it provides
me a beautiful context
to the universe
and how I fit in.
And I'm trying to
tell them that.
And the other thing
you can do, it's
a really cheap birthday present.
Figure out which
star is, let's say,
20 years away, print that
out, give it to your friend,
costs nothing, and it's
a beautiful present, just
a life choice.
- Thank you.
- And I'll just--
I'll add to that really quickly.
It's not something you
ever really get used to.
So I really like
something that Ceili
said this morning or last
night about the first time she
saw the Andromeda Galaxy.
And she said she cried
for like 15 minutes.
That happened to me the
first time I went observing
and I saw all of the stars
in the night sky in Chile
in one of the best observing
sites in the world.
And I had to take a minute
to go outside and just sob,
because you can--
it makes it so real
how many stars and
planets there are.
And so the sheer number
of inhabitable planets
in the world or in the universe
is something that you never
really get used to.
- I'm Alex from
[INAUDIBLE] High School.
And do you think that
non-carbon-based life
forms could exist?
And are you looking for them?
And another question,
do you think
that a life form
would have to be
bipedal to achieve
space flight and go
to other solar system
or another planet?
- So great question.
Let me answer that second
one just very fast.
Nope, because I
think that's more
to do with sci-fi
movie budgets and they
had to fit somebody in there
who had two feet and two legs.
It was cheaper than do CGI.
But the first question
is a very good one.
What about life that's
completely different than ours?
One thing to think
about it this way
is life as we know it is
incredibly good in using what's
around to live or to evolve.
So that's mostly when you
look at the universe, that's
hydrogen, oxygen, and carbon.
So for life to actually
not use carbon and water,
a couple of things
would have to happen.
So for whatever reason, even
chemical, they are favorable.
But if you go to a temperature
range like on Titan
where it's so cold that
water would freeze,
you need another solvent if life
always has RNA, DNA, molecules,
vasculars.
The problem is I don't
know what to look for.
So we're designing our missions
for life as we know it.
We know it involved
the case of one.
If we ever find life on Titan,
we'll do it for a case of two.
But right now, case
of one, and then
we keep our eyes open for
anything weird, because that's
going to be probably
where even the more
interesting discoveries are
going to come from, things
we can't explain.
And then we'll start a whole
new sort of new research area.
- Thank you.
- I'm David Allen.
This is the third
session in which we've
heard how social taboos in
the particular discipline
have prevented data
from coming forward,
important data that then
eventually lead to taboos--
excuse me-- led to
really breakthroughs.
This may not be an
existential crisis.
And we see this kind of
herd-following behavior
very much outside of
scientific disciplines.
But today is about
the undiscovered.
And it's been operationalized
as celebrating failure
and the benefits of failure.
In fact, this
problem of taboos was
addressed in the first
session in talking
about how do you grant tenure
to somebody who's failed.
Let's imagine that this is a
problem of the social climate
in a discipline and,
as I said also, outside
of scientific disciplines.
But that's what we're
talking about today.
If you'd reflect
in your own domain,
and if you please beyond
that and other sciences
or even otherwise,
how might we address
this what appears to
be a problem if we're
going to be serious about not
keeping important data hidden?
- I think one of the
first things I would say
is science is not
never, ever disconnected
from the human endeavor.
We're all humans first.
And then we train as scientists.
So there will always be this
thing where, like, oh this
can't happen.
But then with enough
evidence, we change our ideas.
We say, OK, because
other than that,
we would have never
done this discovery.
Everybody would have
pushed it under the rug.
There's enough mounting
evidence to say OK.
So my human intuition that this
cannot happen is now overrun
by my analytical training that
I have to look at the facts.
But science is a human endeavor.
And it takes time for that
to come through, I think.
- Yeah, I'll just
add to that that I
think this is a really serious
question that you've raised.
And in my mind, the
best way to address it
is by educating kids.
I wish that every funding
agency had the attitude that you
have about risk taking.
But the reality is that we're
accountable to our taxpayers
who often have--
who are taught a
mindset about science
that you have to have your
hypothesis and test it.
And so being uncertain
and doing risky things
and trying to
explore the unknown
is something that we're not very
comfortable with as a society,
I would say.
And so changing
the way science is
taught so that the next
generation of voters
and taxpayers is more
comfortable with this
is, I think, what we should do.
Looking at you,
high school kids.
- So human beings are our
real topic [? thing. ?]
- Yep.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Thank Laura and
Lisa and Dave for
that fantastic conversation.
[APPLAUSE]